you saw the JavaOne who John capper
willow the woman that threw a glass at
John kapralos I see red some guy did
that at the Comedy Store and I was
really big
yeah III was talking about being a Navy
SEAL joking around something like that
and he started he started like defending
the troops or something and I just saw
red like something happened to me where
I was like this guy's trying to be a
tough guy you know and I'm on stage and
I you know me I have that temper like I
just what happens is I have such a long
I have such a long fuse but then once I
see red it's really really I'm gonna
fight I'm gonna go crazy on you and I
just was like I'm gonna [ __ ] I think
this is worth all the jail so what was
he doing was he he suddenly woke up he
shut the [ __ ] up because I I was I was
embarrassed by my own reaction but
something about him pretending to be a
guy standing up for the troops and I was
being insulting made me [ __ ] see red
maybe it was that time of dad if
somebody came on stage and started
punching it that's the only thing but
you would see like it's gonna be a
disaster for them I'll [ __ ] like Marc
Marc Maron loose that's not I'm not
gonna be like that I'm not moral hell no
Marc Maron I you went on like late and I
went up way earlier in the main room
then Marc went on like whatever for
spots after I was just I love Marc yeah
stand up so I sit in the crowd and
there's like too gnarly dude tackling
them like from Australia a dad and a son
and like probably did all the steroids
from koalas like they were jacked and
they kept harassing him and I see the
Comi store like sound guys cos Derick
and Assam mother who worked the front
door and they're like yeah I know
all right well yeah I get everyone cuz
can be a problem so they I tell them the
guys like [ __ ] off and they keep
harassing way mark just lights him on
fire
like but do you just piss he's like what
the [ __ ] you doing so yeah yeah he's a
pro though you know like he goes what
the [ __ ] you doing crowds like dude but
then he gets some bad and he goes and it
was funny is that god damn I walked my
car after their Springer beat me and
like everyone's laughing but these guys
keep going and I'm looking at the comic
store security I'm like oh they're
[ __ ] if these guys want to hurt mark
they're [ __ ] so I hung around just be
the only time where
yeah you gotta hang around oh he's a guy
threatened Chris like I the lease again
yeah so I'm on I'm sitting on the you
know the wall the side of the wall and
there's this guy who's tackling the
comedian's kind of a strong looking dude
the one thing I can't take is a bully
yeah I'm gonna fight yeah I I can't I
can't
so I'm sitting on the wall and he and I
go if he does it I might hard you know
you've been with me where my heart's
delight no no no I'm gonna no he was
heckling Chris and then Chris was
walking and I saw him mark Chris and I
go if he does anything to Chris I'm
gonna fight I said that to some I think
it was somebody was next to me and I my
heart starts beating I go vomit we're
gonna go now I'm gonna go I'm gonna
fight he's coming knock I'm gonna punch
him right there do you like does your
brain in that moment go okay this / I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna I don't know I
don't know I just know her I just know
that it's worth all the jail time and
the risk I'm going I'm going
because I saw him he gets in Chris's
face of his put like that and you can
ask Chris what I did after what Chris do
huh
did chris go chris acts completely
inconvenienced he doesn't get mad the
way I do yeah Chris is like ah dude
whatever the guy the guys and he's a
tough-looking guy
yeah but I'm that's it so now he tries
to come pass me and I get now I get in
this that small space and I'm I'm moving
my shoulders I'm going right on the side
asking him I'm doomed the one thing to
move on me because I want to show him
what I'm gonna do cuz I turn my body I'm
going imagine if I'd let my fist go on
I'm doing this right in front of him
Chris is like and then I thought the
bachelor was his friend and I look at
the bouncer who's this big and I'm so
angry go and do it if you're gonna try
to protect him I'll cut through you like
a [ __ ] knife through a hot butter so
I'm gonna beat you up afterwards is that
your friend I was so angry I'm doing
this he goes like this he he he looks at
me he goes you UFC the UFC I go no I'm
gonna [ __ ] you
I'm losing my mind on and he he goes he
goes he goes this is my spot this is my
spot and you're doing that to my friend
so now we're in a world of trouble
because you're not going anywhere it's
no way I so crazy not imagine a
situation where a comedian who defended
themselves against an audience member
would ever get in trouble look I don't
know what happened to me but Chris is
like staring and the guy I was
this is you have signed up for an
arrangement where you go listen to
someone else talk discouraged and say
nothing but that's how I will with with
Marcus thing you know if these guys got
in stage let's say I knocked them out is
Adam that kicked me out of the car oh
you wanna know I remembered you were you
there the night that someone brushed the
stage
odds to burn in the oro it was wild and
it happened so [ __ ] fast and you know
cuz the oh are at the Comedy Store is so
dark they I mean I trip every time I
want that's me I'm like bags everyone
like stop your [ __ ] tour yourself in
this [ __ ] so I remember someone came and
Steve burn doesn't play around no like I
don't like I didn't also the best guy in
the world I didn't know that about burn
because he's the nicest [ __ ] guy the
first person that was ever nice to me in
comedy it's actually a really
embarrassing story because when I first
started comedy I was on my it was my
space days and I had gotten a spot on
Last Call with Carson Daly don't be
jealous
don't be jealous I don't have 30 to 40
views I want to say see burn reached out
to me was like yo if you're ever in New
York let me get you some spots like okay
I'll hook you up the cellar and enough
and I'm like oh that's a night like out
of nowhere to this day no one's ever
done something like that I've never done
that ever do that it's just so
incredibly time-consuming to be as nice
as it's all the work he called the comic
strip he called the Comedy Cellar
he called when there was an improv in
New York called caroline's he got me
eight spot dozen in a weekend at Steve
Byrne that's why I love him so much
media
on Last Call with Carson Daly so I get
to New York and he's like ooh let me
know for it the same club let's like
meet up great I fully think I'm gonna
have to [ __ ] him fully prepared I'm
fully prepared I'm like God my deodorant
on I'm all set and we meet up and I'm
like fully like okay I guess I have to
date this person like whatever this
exchanges your didn't for dating we're
together he shows up with a model I was
like oh my god he's just this nice and
well he's that nice yeah I'm 22 year old
model and I was like oh you know always
my if you [ __ ] with Steve it's not a
game yeah so so someone rushed though
our um yeah cuz I've seen him cuz I used
to open for him on the road a little bit
and I saw it like a couple times when
people disrespected him it did not go
great and then he like he doesn't he
doesn't tolerate disrespect you know
this guy came out from on stage and Bret
Ernst was there too I just remember
seeing Bratz like run through the
audience over the chairs like and it was
just like okay yeah I think from me I
feel so I'm not a tough guy as you know
I'm not there's nothing compared to the
guys like this I'm nothing but I think
that I feel tougher than a lot of
comedians because they're I always look
at them as dysfunctional misfits and if
somebody's gonna come at them so a good
example as my buddy is it works with
he's a lawyer for children and foster
care and his whole life has been to
protect people he would he'd be the one
who would who would adopt a three-legged
mutt all he does is a caregiver he's
just always been the voice for the for
the Forsaken and the for God this guy
this giant dude he would he went down
says hey can you guys keep it down
because my girlfriend's trying to sleep
in this giant guy goes what are you
gonna do wasn't there but what I'm
saying is that he felt like a coward
because the guy punked him he was he was
Brian I was terrified I know you're
supposed to be you've never thrown a
punch yeah I don't think about this and
this giant guy is putting you in water
that you don't even know how to swim in
yeah I did that's not what your thing is
has make you a coward it means you're a
gentle human being in this guy like
Brendan with cauliflower ears
everybody's gonna be terrible so I feel
always they when Camille
ian's like someone like Chris who's an
innocent who's not thinking about this
and this guy's in his face oh never you
think Chris can fight no I've never
pictured no he said he goes you all
heard something I guess I I said cuz I
remember we were in me and Dov and Chris
he had a tank top on he was walking
around tango this when he was a
featuring for dove and I yeah and this
this brough looking guy just sees Chris
his hairy chest and he's walking all
angry he doesn't give a [ __ ] his body's
all like soft and he looked like he had
it was a pattern he looks so ridiculous
and we're walking through this group and
this rough San Diego thug look in the
fight just looks at Chris and goes
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that and Chris just
goes I caught the whole thing I go did
you see that guy you just like trying to
fight Ewing is there any circumstance
you'd fight he goes I mean no nothing
and I go I mean he goes I guess if
somebody hit my mom I would like tweet
Nash it's not in his DNA he acted the
guy who likes starting [ __ ] more but
won't you know what I mean because he
does why'd you just start you know
physically now he's in Albuquerque and
it's supposed that a copy shop even
dinner by himself
that's just Christmas when he doesn't
like he thinks everyone is in on the
joke yeah some people will never know
who the [ __ ] you're gonna piss off and I
think that they're gonna do when I in
other words chris has never had a
relationship with violence you know it's
afraid of violence and fighting on
street that guy cuz he father you know
what people who knows they're exactly
what's gonna happen
yeah and he mentions oh yeah it's
terrifying
and one less you find a cushon the less
you fight a lot you know I'm say some
words like their struggle City but he's
got English keep in touch
that's because I've been in that right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]